[Musique]
bonsoir à tous je dis 14 novembre
bienvenue dans le journal de tv 60 18 26
minutes d'information locale tout de
suite les titres de cette édition
c'est un projet unique au monde
l'institut de santé par à sport
connectés devraient voir le jour à saint
quentin en yvelines en vue des jo de
un lieu dédié à l'accompagnement des
personnes handicapées dans la pratique
du sport
nous recevons l'initiateur de ce projet
le professeur françois jeunesse
reportage au sein du conseil municipal
des jeunes celui de montigny le
bretonneux hier les 18 élus tenait leur
dernière séance plénière de leur mandat
de deux ans il dresse le bilan de cette
expérience citoyenne et puis cette
exposition se tient la commanderie à
l'occasion de la semaine des écrivains
persécutés au travers de ses dessins le
syrien naji al bukhârî témoigne de
l'horreur vécue lors de son
emprisonnement à damas c'est à voir
jusqu'à est dimanche et nous vous
parlerons aussi de ce spectacle
l'histoire de nos histoires création
théâtre danse hip hop associant est des
personnes en fauteuil roulant une
représentation est prévue demain à magny
les hameaux
on va du côté de montigny le bretonneux
tout de suite dans ce journal après deux
ans de mandat pour le conseil municipal
des jeunes il tenait hier soir sa
dernière séance plénière l'occasion de
faire un bilan et aussi de susciter
pourquoi pas de nouvelles vocations pour
les prochaines élections le reportage de
marie lehn iapichino dernière séance
plénière pour les 18 membres du conseil
municipal des jeunes de
montigny-le-bretonneux
après deux ans de mandat il dresse leur
bilan de cette expérience citoyenne
on a amené lui ni dès le tournoi depuis
les bleds le rallye citoyen et on a fait
toutes les commémorations du 11 novembre
et du 8 mai un mandat qui lui a donné le
goût de l'engagement il là ne se
représentera pas mais il compte bien
intégrer un collectif de jeunes
défenseurs du climat pour leur vie
future c'est ce qu'on disait c'est très
enrichissant et sacré en fait une ville
où chacun peut s'impliquer à sa mesure
sur différents sujets c'est plus
passionnant le cmj existe depuis 30 ans
à montigny le bretonneux mener à bout
des projets s'impliquer dans la vie
locale et citoyenne
c'est aussi un moyen de prendre
confiance en soi et grandir entre jeunes
encadrés par une coordinatrice
j'ai appris déjà m'affirmer ce qu'avant
j'étais assez timide j'ai pu partager
mes idées avec les autres sans avoir
spécialement à être coupés on a tous pu
s'entendre vraiment sont deux années qui
ont été pleines de jouer à plein de
bonheur plein d'apprentissage et c'est
qu'elles sont deux années qui m'ont
beaucoup plu
manon compte bien renouveler
l'expérience et présentera sa
candidature pour un prochain mandat
ouvert à tous les jeunes du cm2 à la
seconde vous avez jusqu'au 25 novembre
pour remplir votre dossier et leur
apporter en mairie ou pôle jeunesse
à vous ensuite de convaincre durant
votre campagne avant les élections qui
se dérouleront dans les établissements
scolaires de la ville du 9 au 13
décembre dans l'actualité la
mobilisation aujourd'hui du personnel
hospitalier grève pour dénoncer
notamment le manque d'effectifs et de
moyens dans les hôpitaux
de nombreux professionnels de santé des
yvelines et était dans le mouvement
aujourd'hui ont participé à ce mouvement
qui a perturbé le fonctionnement des
établissements de santé
ça a été le cas notamment à l'hôpital de
poissy saint germain mantes-la-jolie et
osseux aussi au centre hospitalier andré
mignot averse a eu une mobilisation
assez tenue dans le hall d'accueil les
participants se sont allongés par terre
et dénoncés ont dénoncé je cite la mort
de l'hôpital public une nouvelle action
est prévue pour la journée du 21
novembre
un événement pour la lutte contre le
cancer justement au profit du centre
hospitalier de versailles le premier
cycle au cancer francilien a permis de
récolter trois mille cinq cent soixante
euros le chèque a été remis au service
pédiatrique de l'hôpital andré mignot l
argent servira à améliorer le quotidien
des enfants soignés au sein de cette
unité
le cyclo cancer s'était tenue pour
rappel le 13 octobre dernier et c'était
à maurepas
un projet novateur qui pourrait voir le
jour à saint quentin en yvelines
l'institut de santé par à sport
connectée est dix mille mètres carrés
pour accompagner les personnes en
situation de handicap dans la pratique
du sport
tout au long de leur vie avec nous en
plateau l'initiateur de ce projet c'est
le professeur françois genest bonsoir
bonsoir
alors vous êtes médecin spécialisé dans
la médecine physique et de réadaptation
à l'hôpital raymond poincaré à garches
c'est un projet qui pourrait voir le
jour en 2024 à l'occasion des jeux
olympiques et paralympiques de paris
pourquoi imaginer ce projet à écouter
l'espérance de vie des personnes en
situation de handicap ne fait
qu'augmenter la qualité de vie également
et on s'est rendu compte que l'activité
physique et le sport qui est le premier
rempart contre la maladie chronique et
contre la récidive était très important
et à structurer et surtout n'existait
pas aujourd'hui ni sur notre région ni
dans notre pays ni d'ailleurs à
l'échelle internationale c'est comment
structurer le sport le handicap et
organiser tout ça autour d'une prise en
charge de très haut niveau
donc c'est un type de structure
aujourd'hui qui n'existent pas ce serait
unique de le devoir d'avoir ce type de
structure tout à fait aujourd'hui des
évaluations qu'on a fait dans le monde
entier nous permettent pas aujourd'hui
de retrouver une structure qui aurait ce
niveau d'évaluation est surtout utilisé
les compétences du plateau de saclay
notamment en termes de dévaluation
numérique et de tout et de toutes ces
technologies
ce chiffre 49% des personnes en
situation de handicap suite à un
accident disent d'abord arrêter le sport
sans accompagnement aujourd'hui c'est
difficile de s'y remettre à cette
pratique sportive
oui nos évaluations nous ont permis de
mesurer que rock faire du sport quand on
est en situation de handicap c'est
compliqué pour plusieurs raisons la
première c'est que la médecine est
souvent un frein le certificat
d'aptitude
comment autoriser quelqu'un déjà blessé
à pouvoir faire une activité sportive
avec des risques qu'il faut mesurer est
le 2 le deuxième frein basse et le
maillage territorial c'est ou pratiquer
le troisième français le caractère
inclusif c'est à dire exposer son corps
à la pratique sportive avec eux d'autres
personnes qui n'ont pas ces handicaps et
parfois un peu compliqué en terme
d'image corporelle
mais pourquoi justement cette pratique
sportive est primordial est importante
dans la reconstruction psychologique via
le sport est l'un des vecteurs qui
permet à ses patients de pouvoir
retrouver de nouveaux objectifs de
trouver de nouveaux plaisirs
essentiellement est également de se
réapproprier un nouveau corps d'aimé à
nouveau son corps et se permettre de
fait d'avoir un meilleur suivi et de
vivre plus longtemps dans de meilleures
conditions
si on revient sur l'institut donc dix
mille m² implantés à 50 on dit en
yvelines pardon comment ça va
fonctionner concrètement alors l'idée
c'est d'exploiter la référence national
de recherche sur l'intelligence
artificielle et le numérique sur notre
site d'y ajouter les compétences de
notre université versailles saint
quentin en yvelines et surtout du fr
simone veil santé dans le cadre du paris
saclay l'idée c'est d'allier santé
formation recherche sur un même
exactement l'année c'est exactement ça
c'est de faire un pôle santé de
référence nationale en y associant la
recherche et la formation autour du para
sport qu'est ce qu'un lieu a déjà été
identifié justement à saint quentin en
yvelines
on va vous vous imaginez on a déjà des
discussions très très rapprochés avec la
communauté d'agglomération et notamment
son président pour déterminer différents
secteurs nous avons aujourd'hui
plusieurs options et nous sommes en
train de discuter avec l'agglomération
pour pouvoir déterminer un secteur vous
avez le feu vert de l'agglomération
aujourd'hui bal l'agglomération nous
donne
un soutien très bienveillant nous aide à
la construction de ce projet de manière
très très active aujourd'hui en fonction
des différents acteurs on est sur un
projet hybride
il faut qu'on détermine le secteur le
secteur géographique qui est
prédéterminée mais qui pour l'instant
n'est pas encore complètement validé et
pourquoi la chine est en tout cas ce
projet ici à saint quentin en yvelines m
sur place à la fois les compétences
d'une université et d'un hôpital sur le
handicap 10 mètres à la fois les
compétences numériques et technologiques
et enfin on est un site olympique et de
pouvoir montrer à la france à
l'ouverture des jeux paralympiques ce
qui est capable de faire ce pays pour le
sport et le handicap est une ambition
qui nous paraît légitime et qui ne peut
être qu'à cet endroit finalement il
toutes les conditions pour être
réunifiée vous l'avez dit sites
olympiques avec de nombreuses épreuves
qui pourrait être qui seront organisées
sur le territoire de saint quentin du
coup on en est le projet quel est le
calendrier en tout cas que vous avez
imaginé écouter aujourd'hui on a une
discussion qui est au plus haut niveau
d'états nous avons une réunion avec tous
les ministères impliqués la région
l'assistance publique-hôpitaux de paris
d'université et le comité
d'agglomération pour déterminer un go
nogo qui devrait arriver dès début
décembre et on est très très optimiste
pour l'instant c'est un projet qui
pourrait voir le jour pour qu'il voie le
jour il faut qu'il ait le soutien de
tous les niveaux l'état la région le
département et l'agglomération
exactement il n'est pas possible de
monter un projet de cette dimension là
sans avoir l'assentiment et et le
soutien de l'ensemble de ses forces qui
aujourd'hui regarde notre projet avec
beaucoup d'intérêt et nous soutiennent
et le coût d'un tel projet ce qu'on
arrive à à l'estimer oui aujourd'hui
alors ce ne sont encore que des
évaluations qui sont faits par des
sociétés conseils sur sur le projet en
lui même on est sur des autour de 40
millions d'euros
merci professeur je n'ai d'être venu en
parler en plateau à cet institut de
santé par à sport connectés qui pourrait
donc voir le jour à saint quentin en
yvelines on suivra avec attention en
tout cas l'évolution de ce projet à
suivre dans un instant un autre projet à
cette fois ci à culturel qui associés
justement des personnes en situation de
handicap
merci pour votre passage en plateau
et rapprocher les jeunes et la police au
travers d'activités sportives et
ludiques l'objectif du dispositif proxy
raid aventure il faisait étape le
week-end dernier à plaisir une journée
citoyenne et sportive qui nous est
présenté par aurélie rond et michael et
demi d'euros créée par un ancien
fonctionnaire de police du raid prox
raid aventure sillonnent le territoire
français avec un seul but rapprocher les
jeunes la population et la police
pour cela une dizaine de stands
permettaient de tester plusieurs
activités au palais des sports de
plaisir
et
c'est bien parce qu'on apprend à se
défendre si on se fait agresser dans la
rue il ya quand même des jeunes qui
pensaient qu'on n'était pas des vrais
policiers et le fait qu'on ait fait du
sol avec eux
son diary on n'a joué que la police
prend ça crée des liens parce que du
coup son compte en self défense laser
game box secourisme encore techniques
d'interpellation en proposant ses
activités ludiques les policiers venus
bénévolement sur leur temps libre espère
changer leur image auprès du public
on a toujours un peu des questions drôle
par rapport à l' usage de l'armement
on leur explique la réalité du terrain
en fait on est là pour casser un peu
les stéréotypes qu'ils peuvent voir dans
les différentes séries policières soit
américaine ou même parfois française
aujourd'hui les jeunes ne respectent
plus la police et au contraire ça renou
le lien on va dire on les voit plus
comme les médecins etc sont en cours
arrêtés ils sont comme nous quoi chaque
année ce dispositif s'arrête dans près
de 70 villes notamment celles où se
trouvent des quartiers considérés comme
sensibles
c'est une bonne idée avec les les tout
ce qui s'est passé ces derniers temps là
avec les attaques du vally bout ça
sensibilise un peu le public
c'est la première fois que provoque ce
raid aventure faisait étape à plaisir
une opération qui a vocation à se
renouveler
ils sont 87 87 sites reconnus
aujourd'hui patrimoine d'intérêt
régional par l'ile-de-france un label
pour préserver ces sites non protégé
depuis le mois de septembre saint
quentin en yvelines en compte 3 est la
perspective de martha padmé ta de nice
mme mercado et la porte de paris de
piotr kowalski les précisions de mélanie
poké elle vous fait entrer dans saint
quentin en yvelines depuis les années 90
la porte de paris de piotr kowalski tout
proche du vélodrome et depuis le mois de
septembre
labellisé patrimoine d'intérêt régional
nous sommes à proximité de l'autoroute
a16 et donc l'idée des urbanistes à
l'époque plutôt d'avoir une simple
bretelle d'autoroute qui pénètre dans la
ville nouvelle
l'idée était d'avoir une véritable
entrée de ville marquer comme il se doit
avec cette arche monumental autour d'un
rond point qui permet de distribuer les
les différentes routes d'accès et
notamment l' axe qui se dirige tout
droit vers
vers la place pompidou comme la porte de
paris deux autres avons obtenu ce label
lancé par la région en 2017
trois oeuvres qui ont un point commun la
monumentalité c'est à la fois
un label comme je disais de
reconnaissance et qui montre que ce que
cet art public en partie au patrimoine à
part entière y'a pas de fait finalement
il n'y a pas de petits et de grands
patrimoines et c'est aussi à la belle
qui permet de mettre l'accent sur cette
particularité des villes nouvelles de
l'art public au sein des villes
nouvelles qui est quand même une des
caractéristiques assez forte de ses
oeuvres se parle avec un fil conducteur
la bièvre méthadone ici mme mercado
marque les débuts du canal urbain une
oeuvre de 92 qui appelle celle de marta
pan à guyancourt
la perspective qui est une oeuvre de
transition entre la ville et la campagne
et l'idée en fait des aménageurs à
l'époque de l'établissement public
d'aménagement était de concevoir ce
circuit d'eau en l'accompagnant
d'oeuvres d'art on a mis en place ce
qu'on appelle une étude préalable pour
autour de la perspective de martha panne
pour en étudier
la restauration futur label permet une
aide en investissement pour la
restauration et de fonctionnement pour
sa valorisation 51 ans neeve et une
possède 40 oeuvres d'art urbain
l'agglomération réfléchit à mettre en
avant les oeuvres du pôle elancourt mort
pas là des personnes en fauteuil roulant
sur scène au contact de comédiens
amateurs et professionnels et d'une
compagnie de danse hip hop l'histoire de
nos histoires continue son chemin et
demain la création sera joué à la maison
de l'environnement de magny les hameaux
mise en scène détiennent quichard
chorégraphie signée ifra dia et on en
parle avec vous jean djoman bonsoir
bonsoir cofondateur de la compagnie
black blanc beur elle a rejoint ce
projet de l'association vivre debout qui
soutient lé personnes en situation de
handicap et aussi dans ce projet il ya
l'association du théâtre de sable ce
spectacle on peut le dire il est né
avant tout deux rencontres oui alors il
est né surtout d'une nécessité c'était
vivre debout qui voulait fêter ses 40
ans nous étions au mois d'août 2014
et là ils ont fait un peu le tour des
artistes disponibles pour savoir comment
organiser une petite fête au réfectoire
de l'école des friches et donc j'ai fait
partie des gens qui ont été contactés là
dessus j'ai fait un peu le tour ma doute
tout le monde n'était pas là bref
etienne est arrivé tout de suite avec
son grand coeur il ya aussi pôle bringel
un éclairagiste un créateur lumière que
tout le monde connaît bien ici et tous
les trois on a fait une sorte de popote
pour ce jour d'octobre de leur
anniversaire et 7 popote
c'est une véritable histoire une belle
histoire entre nous qu'on a qu'on n'a
pas voulu arrêter compte qu'on n'a même
pas su qu'on a qu'on ne voulait pas
arrêté l'été une évidence pour les baies
3 la compagnie pionnière de la danse hip
hop en france de vie de venir soit la
nature même de notre démarche c'est une
démarche qui part de d'habitants qui
racontent leur histoire qu'ils
s'approprient des moyens artistiques et
qui avec sa développe une esthétique un
langage quelque chose qui leur permet de
raconter leur propre histoire et ça
c'est le point commun avec ce spectacle
histoires de nos histoires ce processus
qui s'appelle prises en compte
1 c'est au mts je vous laisse saisir le
jeu de mots ce qui est intéressant c'est
que c'est tout à fait le projet qui à la
verse des démarches classiques
institutionnels star c'est quelque chose
qui n'ait pas projeté depuis
l'institution mais c'est quelque chose
qui arrive comme une nécessité
l'entité que les gens ont de se
retrouver entre eux et de se faire leur
propre histoire je pense que le fond de
l'histoire c'est ça et sur ce projet en
tout cas pour les blagues landers et les
baies 3 juniors qui ont été ainsi les
juniors naturellement de toute façon
l'équipe historique aujourd'hui est
relativement bon voilà on est en train
de passer à autre chose qu'est stinat un
duo qui sortira peut-être en 2020 quand
après les élections quand les choses
sont un tout petit peu tassé explique
aulas absolument critique ou d'un don
qui la chorégraphe des blacks blancs
beurs et cofondatrice avec moi parce que
j'ai vu son travail et je pense que ça
mérite d'être vu mais le sujet ce soir
c'est que voilà c'est la troisième fois
qu'on présente histoires de nos
histoires
il faut venir voir alors je rectifie
c'est pas dix personnes en fauteuil
il y en a là dans le spectacle 4 autour
de nous et en asie personne en fauteuil
voilà parce qu'une autre particularité
c'est que les gens sont venus là en leur
qualité d'habitants oui avec une
singularité pour certains en fauteuil
d'autres qui sont debout mais vous savez
au bout du bout le fauteuil des fois on
l'a dans la tête
donc quelque part face à un plateau tous
ces amateurs avec celle amateurs et
professionnels voilà mais face au
plateau tout le monde des amateurs 1
donc voilà effectivement ce sont des
sacrés personnages quoi et et ses 16 ans
de travail trois ans et demi de travail
c'est trois ans processus six mois
d'observation d'ateliers et voilà déjà
maintenant un autre spectacle existe et
qui s'affine
j'espère qu'on pourra de le présenter à
nouveau notamment de
il ya un festival s'appelle orphée qui
est consacré aux formes d'expressions
liées au handicap donc voilà mes rendez
vous demain à 20h30 donc à la maison de
l'environnement parce que bombe à chaque
spectacle on s'améliore alors donc ça
c'est pour demain à la prochaine
représentation la maison de
l'environnement
si on fait le bilan alors on n'en est
pas encore à la fin de ce projet mais si
on fait le bilan côté b3 qu'est ce que
ça apporte est justement à la compagnie
doit partir à partir du moment où on
sort des sentiers battus qu'on est
obligé de se poser la question de la
manière dont les autres comprennent ce
qu'on raconte est la manière dont on
comprend ce qu'ils nous disent que ce
soit dans un processus de spectacle ou
autrement
sa force la capacité à mieux vivre
ensemble
l'intérêt du spectacle qui a en plus un
enjeu il y à un espace comme ça qui rend
fabrique du désir de la stimulation
donc ça c'est un plus à partir de là
pour les danseurs ce extraordinaire sa
force leur écoute ça les oblige à
réfléchir autrement que quand ils sont
entre professionnels du même grade
l'objectif c'est que de continuer à
jouer ce spectacle peut être monter
aussi d'autres projets pourquoi pas elle
avait su parce que spectacle sa valeur
c'est pas de se rentabiliser de fabrique
ou tant qu'à faire autant le vendre
correctement ce sera mieux mais
l'important c'est surtout que c'est un
endroit où on se retrouve et où on
n'étaye où on enrichit nos relations et
ses relations
elles reviennent dans les quartiers
parce que c'est quelque chose qui est
une émanation des quartiers donc il ya
là une sorte de cercle vertueux qui fait
qui met au premier plan
l'histoire des gens eux-mêmes et moi je
pense que c'est vraiment notre combat
dans black blanc beur comme dans ce
projet mené par et yann guichard et et
ifrad ya l'histoire de nos histoires à
voir demain à la maison de
l'environnement à magny les hameaux
c'est à 20h30 infos et réservations via
les liens qui s'affiche en bas de
l'écran merci janvier
en plateau depuis neuf ans les
itinéraires politique de saint quentin
en yvelines organise la semaine des
écrivains persécutés emprisonnés empêché
plusieurs animations au programme
notamment cette exposition celle de
najah al boukai l'artiste syrien montre
ses dessins poignant sur
l'emprisonnement à la commanderie à
d'elancourt découverte de cette
exposition avec manon par aldo et
patrick jacques de dixmude destiné pour
ne pas oublier c'est ce que fait najah
al boukai professeur de dessin dans une
université syrienne il n'est ni de jadis
ni membre de rébellion mais suite à une
dénonciation à partir de 2012 il a été
fiché et enfermée pour avoir participé à
des manifestations
il se retrouve emprisonné à damas ce
centre 227 gérés par les services de
renseignements militaires
najah al boukai a été frappé torturé
humilié il a vécu là
des horreurs des abominations
il en est sorti s'en est échappée il a
réussi à se réfugier en france est
accueillie aidé par l'ambassade de
france et ici l'ami des images sur ce
qu'il a vécu à travers ces descend il
raconte l'horreur qu'il a vécu il survit
aux côtés de plusieurs codétenus dont
certains agonisé pendant des jours sous
ses yeux
ils sont décédés de maladies de torture
ou encore d'étranglement perpétré à
mains nues les survivants débarrasser
eux mêmes les corps conduits ensuite
dans des fosses communes
les corps suspendu et les coups de bâton
donner donner à ces personnes qui pour
la plupart sont là parce qu'elles ont
voulu exprimer un besoin de liberté
kolo qu'on leur a empêché de de données
de partager et donc voilà c'est toute
cette violence là qui existe et qu'on
voudrait bien abolir et on sait que ça
va pas en s'arrangeant
exilé en france najac du cas ils
témoignent au travers de ses dessins et
gravures les atrocités qu'il a subies
car à 4000 km de là la guerre continue
et certains prisonniers n'ont pas
échappé à la barbarie une exposition à
voir à la commanderie jusqu'à dimanche
l'entrée est libre najah le bouquet qui
sera l'invité demain soir de la 9e
soirée des écrivains à persécuter seront
présents également le journaliste
congolais glisse fortunés dont bemba le
bédéiste papa divin ou encore le poète
soudanais à mohammed nour ouanna c'est à
la commanderie à elancourt à partir de
20 heures
et puis une page musicale le quatrième
tremplin fait des groupes s'est déroulée
le week-end dernier c'était à la merise
attrape sept groupes heavy noah sur
scène devant un jury de professionnels
michael et demi d'euros
essai
on joue
une bataille musicale à la mairie ce
samedi 9 novembre sept groupes du bas
saint yvi mois compositeur et interprète
se sont produits sur scène pour cette
quatrième édition du tremplin fait des
groupes à la merise ça représente
peut-être un tremplin ou peut-être en
tout cas déjà touché toucher des gens
principalement quand il ya plein de
groupes locaux et c'est ça qui est
intéressant de pouvoir rencontrer aussi
des musiciens du département quoi il ya
un écho concert un bon jour c'est la
possibilité de jouer dans des conditions
professionnelles
encore une fois dans un ancrage local
c'est à côté de chez nous et on est
dépendant des noirs les sept groupes
présents ont été sélectionnés sur
plusieurs mois
chaque groupe candidate déjà dans les
critères il faut que ça soit des
compositions 6 et des reprises on ne
prend pas des groupes ensuite
deuxièmement faut vraiment qu'ils soient
du bassin pourrait que nous on fait une
première écoute
voilà et de là on sélectionne pas entre
sept et huit groupes et ensuite ils
passent devant nous sur scène dans des
conditions réelles et à ce moment là bas
il ya un vote à la fois du public mais
également du jury le jury composé de
professionnels du son de directeur de
celles aidées lui accorde 20 minutes sur
ce n est pas une seconde de plus le jury
vote sur la fois la présence scénique la
musicalité le texte la technicité et là
on finit avec une note à 20 dont une
note de 1 à 5 pour chacun de ces
paramètres et on finit avec une note
voilà sur 20 après délibération cette
année le gagnant du tremplin et
finalement thiec du rap venons de
trappes pas besoin de damblain juba d'un
homme et je vais
le groupe remporté un passage sur la
scène de la merise en première partie
d'un spectacle pour les entendre il
faudra patienter jusqu'à la prochaine
saison culturelle 2020 à 2021
avant de vous laisser mélanie poké
bonsoir ça de la rédaction de tv 78 pas
de sélection d'idées de sorties ce soir
comme c'est tu as l'habitude à
l'habitude pour le journal du jeudi
mais pas de panique on vous retrouve
dans quelques instants dans l'émission
c'est eu le loisir vous allez nous
parler de quoi que ce soit d'ailleurs
plusieurs rendez vous comme chaque
semaine est le premier dans le premier
on parlera de vitesse universal circuit
à maurepas et passer à l'électrique
alors 22 cartes vous attendent sur la
piste mais qu'elle elle met dos
notre journaliste sportif lui a testé
les nouveaux bolides et la piste millan
aussi pour les passionnés de cyclisme ou
les curieux il faudra aller au vélodrome
nationale puisque le site accueille ce
week-end la deuxième édition du gala
star en piste des animations sont
programmées en présence de
professionnels de la piste et de la
route de la route pardon et on leur
parlera aussi un peu de cinéma de jeu et
de bien-être
le 7-8 loisirs a retrouvé donc dans
quelques instants avec vous mais la nuit
voilà c'est la fin de ce journal merci
de l'avoir suivi demain vendredi place
aux 7,8 l'hebdo pour revenir sur
l'essentiel de l'actualité de la semaine
quant à nous on se retrouve dès lundi
pour une nouvelle édition du journal
d'information locale belle soirée sur tv
[Musique]